welcome back to new rock stars and as
mutants inch closer and closer to the
mcu everybody and their mutant mamas
have been wondering just how the edge
gene will be triggered within mcu
humanity well what if i told you that
king the conqueror himself will be the
one to introduce mutants just because it
was something to do
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitched the wildest series for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is mt and
going with me today is the future owner
of the phoenix force it is jessica jean
grey clemens what's going on jessica
and also
it is the future of owner of the x-men
basketball
team sorry um and also the future leader
of the x-men it is off-screen producer
brandon uh cyclops barrick what's going
on i'll take that buddy give me that
cyclops power any day you people might
hate on cyclops you might call him a
nerd he's going to laser your arms off
you better back up you got to watch out
i genuinely love cyclops it's jubilee
okay i don't want to hear that
jubilee slander get out of here listen
get out oh yeah you both of you get out
yeah you came to the wrong you came to
the wrong house you came to the wrong
house with that those are my opposite
beliefs
cyclops useless jubilee
where it's at pew pew pew pew pew pew
pew pew pew pew pew pew that's her this
is her there's her pew pew pew pew
people
so she sets one of those off in your
brain and kills you
look out exactly look out whatever fire
fireworks in the brain that's instant
damage that's what i hear um
all right guys speaking of mutants which
is why we did the intro very mutants
like um but let's let's talk about how
mutants will come into the mcu or how i
think mutants will come to the mcu and i
think that kang the conqueror himself
will be the one to do it specifically in
ant-man and the wasp quantomania because
check this out gang quantum mania the
reason why the movie is called quantum
mania is because i believe it's going to
be dealing with quantum energy that's
that really that magical stuff that
janet van dyne was filled with when she
was uh picked up from the quantum realm
when she was picked up jenna van dyne
tells her husband that she's no longer
the same woman that she was 30 years ago
and that this place is tied to evolution
and that this quantum energy is seeming
to allude that this quantum energy is
tied to evolution itself and i think
that quantum mania is going to deal with
the coming of this quantum energy to the
mcu populace and i think that kang the
conqueror will be the one to release
this quantum energy throughout the
entire mcu earth and uh to trigger the
x-gene mutation within the mcu what do
you guys think
i could see it
i could see it
it's okay
yeah this this whole quantum energy
thing you know her
janet's powers and like how she comes
out she like heals ghosts and like my
you know they don't really talk about it
i want to know a lot more about that
like what is this stuff how was she
living down there how it changed her but
i like this idea that it's somehow tied
to the x gene now in theory mt this kang
right he's seen mutants before if this
is like a kang that's conquered other
uh universes right he's seen mutants is
do you think he's caused him in other
places like is kang always the one
causing the mutants or is he like oh
there's no mutants in this one i better
add him in so i can fight him and kill
him
i think that kang could have like
crippled the mutants like what went like
specifically could have not wanted the
mutants to emerge so that he could
conquer easily because like that's what
you're gonna do if you see a problem
coming it's like let's stop mutants from
rising and let's just conquer from the
avengers on but like now that he's like
all right this is round two let me uh
turn up the difficulty level and uh turn
on mutant this time and let's see if i
can conquer with mutants um yeah i think
it's just a matter of like making things
a little bit more challenging for like
adding more weight to his his dumbbells
he's like all right more resistance i
have a question
go for it question
do you think that kang is the only one
that could have brought
like created the you're saying the x-men
gene right you're saying the mutant gene
he created well i'm saying that um i'm
saying that the mutant gene is within
humanity already that's probably given
to them by the celestials i think that
the actual trigger of the mutant gene
will be this quantum energy that like
enters um the bodies of humanity
through kane
is like i think kang is gonna release
this radiation out into the world and
the radiation is gonna trigger the gene
and some people that have it and uh it's
gonna okay great mutants do you think do
you think there's not another person
other than king and other don't you so
do you think that um
hank pym's wife
what's your name
what's your name
uh do you not think hey pims wife could
have given people that same
[Music]
hold for motorcycle
do you do you not think that hank pym's
wife could have accidentally given
people also the gene then by
proxy because she has the same stuff
right like it's just leaking out of her
well she could give it to like
the
the scott lang's daughter
okay
it's that's potentially true like she
like if she's within proximity if she's
touching people she could potentially
activate the x gene i feel um with this
theory anyway um but yeah i think that
janet van dyne could be a source of
evolution if she still has that energy
within her but i was going to say that
but it seems like from the end of
ant-man 2 that janet doesn't really have
as much energy as she used to when she
uh touched the truth which is why 100
percent had to go back to the quantum
realm
do you think kane can also so can could
just like take it back from those people
maybe um but i think king would probably
just go to the quantum realm and grab
some more and just like
go off
go off go open that fridge and take as
much as you want it makes me wonder if
that if that he who remains was keeping
the mutants uh sequestered in the 616
for like a reason is it like maybe the
mutants wind up like helping kang every
time in in some weird way either like
kang like mobilizes mutants in a unique
way to help take over the world or they
inadvertently like help kang
either by opening portals or doing some
weird mutant thing that he who remains
in the 616 was like we got to make sure
mutants don't happen so that he writes
the you know he paves the road so
there's no mutants on on the highway uh
but uh the kang that comes in in
quantomania is like i need the mutants
here baby uh because they they help me
out they don't know it but they stir it
up so i'm gonna let them go i'm gonna
start
i i just keep thinking that there there
has to be like multiple ways they can be
brought in and multiple ways they are
brought in where it's not just kang in
the quantum mania i think it's like
other people can be like this is my
adjacent x-men gene like something that
still makes them like awakens them but
maybe makes them not
crazy i don't know i just i i believe it
i believe it and i see it and i think
what i do like about your theory and it
does have to come in with someone big
and i think coming in with kang is a
good idea to start it i'm ripping pieces
of my chair off i'm sorry
devour the chat no i
i think it like i honestly feel like
quantum energy will be the reason why
um
modok is has a big head in the movie
because like we know that modoc is gonna
be uh the uh the other villain alongside
kang and i feel like you know because we
know that this quantum energy can you
know heal the
interface with the body as we see from a
ghost and uh with um hank pym in the
quantum realm like she touches their
heads and their bodies you know become
different and healed i feel like
like intense radiation like intense
concentrations of this quantum radiation
could potentially make someone's head
really big if you put a lot of and like
in your body and which is why we're
gonna probably get modoc because he
wants all that super sweet energy in his
body that's just me saying random things
no it's okay is the quantum so is the
quantum a is that gonna be the terrigen
mist
basically for the mutants i feel like
it's sort of gonna be like in a way the
terrorism is for the mutants um and sort
of just activate that gene within
humanity but like
not really in the same way because like
the terrorism miss like you get a whole
cocoon around your body it's like it's a
whole thing but like and it's it's very
similar in that way i feel um with this
theory anyway
i think it would be really cool if kang
shows up in quantum mania uh and he's
like i'm gonna create the mutants here
in the 616. and he has a machine that
he's stolen from another universe that
he's taken over and it's the same
machine
uh from the first x-men that magneto was
using on the statue of liberty to turn
people into mutants he's he's been to
that universe he's conquered it he's
taken that machine and he's kept it in
chronopolis or wherever he lives in the
quantum realm he's like now i'm going to
use it on the 616 baby here we go
from the x-men like so he's he's so
basically he said like he's going to use
that to trigger mutants again yeah he's
got he's been to that universe he's
conquered it he's stolen that machine
and he's bringing it to the 616.
[Music]
okay no i love that theory i i would
love if kevin feige brought back the
x-men one plot
to like a future mcu movie just to tie
it all together because like we know
that like he he's all about you know
bringing toby maguire back like it's
just respecting the old the old marvel
movies that like sort of started it off
where the uh for the mcu so like i feel
like tying it back into x-men one would
be very poetic and and inappropriate i
feel um with the coming of the mutants i
would dig that a lot i would really be a
big fan
um
if the oh well if the machine didn't
kill everybody that would be ideal
ideal he's fixed it he's fixed it a
little bit so that machine did not work
in x-men one all right gay so voting
time so about this theory with kang the
conqueror being the one that brings the
x-men to the mcu do you guys give it a
rogues a bogus or an ogus i have no
strong feelings one way or the other
august is literally like officially part
of the show just it's official
because of me you invented the yogurt
the thing here let me talk let me talk
about my reasoning i don't think it's
bogus i don't think it's bogus i'll tell
you that right now it's not both okay
i want to give it
also a good start
the only reason i would give it an ogus
is because i'm like yeah i can see it
that's it i'm like this i can see it
it's not like shaking me to my core it's
nice rogue it's just like yeah but it is
rogus
to be like kang's using
that energy to give people
that like kang is just king so it's like
the
the hank pym's wife could be like uh
oh my gosh i had that power too but i'm
not as strong as that guy is and i can't
just give it to people so i like that
part i think that's what makes it rogus
so i will give you a rogus because
okay if you did the math correct you
still but the answer might be wrong i'm
still going to award you
you know yeah
that's correct but for some reason you
just put in a four instead of a two i
want to go to this school
i'm i'll take it thank you jessica
i will give it i'm going to give it a a
very solid bogus i'm going to give it
ogus
i like i like the idea of carrying
making the mutants i do like that idea
but i think it's not just because he
wants a challenge or he you know for for
for sngs you know what i mean he just
wants he wants to go
he needs the mutants in some way and
they're important to his plan and that's
why he who remains had kept them out for
so long uh so i'll give it an ogus i
like that i love that are you giving him
an ogus
are you giving him an ogus because your
theory deserves a rogue is
not
not my theory i mean my theory is you
just said it
i know my theory is great it's not on
it's not on my nose it's pretty dope i
love you he's like here's my theory
my theory stands on the shoulders of
mt's theory he did it he did all the
work he did all the math
my answer is better but he did all the
math work so i'll let him happy i love
his answer a lot so i so i will take
that over he got mt got me there this is
mt's idea i just
this sounds too much like real hollywood
and i don't like it i mean
don't let this [ __ ] take your
ideas i like what is the meme when it's
like i like this this is mine now this
is mine this is mine now
aurogas and nogus i will take that
that's the name of my new sitcom
rogerson and august but up next jessica
has a really interesting theory that you
guys have to hear but first be sure to
head on over to newrockstarsmerch.com
where you can still grab our newest
latest obsession shirt inspired by thor
love and thunder before it's gone for
good because it will be gone for good
very soon and check out the all-new epic
kids line presented by our partners at
epic hero shop it is the perfect space
to do some back to school shopping for
the little nerds in your life so support
all the awesome work we do over here at
new rockstars by checking out all the
merch options over at new
rockstarsmerch.com and we want to thank
upside for sponsoring this video because
whether you are absolutely stunned when
you fill up your car at the gas station
or you have noticed the prices at your
favorite restaurant have started to
creep up and up one thing is clear
inflation is the worst and it's hitting
us all where it hurts and it really
really hurts and that's why many of us
here at new rockstars have started using
upside upside is an incredible app for
anyone who buys gas groceries or dines
out with every purchase you can earn
cash back thanks to upside to get
started download the free upside app in
the app store or google play and use our
promo code rogue theory and get five
dollars or more cash back on your first
purchase of 10 or more next claim an
offer for whatever you're buying on
upside check in at the business pay as
usual with a credit card or debit card
and get paid in comparison to credit
card rewards or loyalty programs you can
earn three times more cash back with
upside you can cash out any time to your
bank account paypal or an e-gift card
for amazon and other brands upside users
are earning more than a million dollars
every week which is pretty crazy that's
probably why they have a 4.8 star rating
on the app store oscar producer brandon
uses upside all the time and it's the
best way to find a place to eat on a
friday night all you have to do is
search for a restaurant that you like
that also has a reward offer it's a
win-win it's a really good deal so
download the free upside app and use
promo code rogue theory to get five
dollars or more cash back on your first
purchase of ten dollars or more that's
five dollars or more cash back on your
first purchase of ten dollars or more
using promo code rogue theory now it is
time for our second topic for today
which will be presented by the lovely
jessica clemens what's going on just hit
us with that theory
me me me okay so
my rogue theory that i brought up to
brandon yesterday to make sure it was
actually good
that's how you sway the judges and broke
theory
um
i think she hulk is either going to join
the thunderbolts or the thunderbolts are
going to be definitely a post-credits
scene to the very at last episode of uh
of uh she-hulk so
so why i think this so i think um as we
have abomination as we have uh the whole
bruce banner and we have titania i think
there's gonna be so and matt murdock i
think there's gonna be a lot of
confliction in the comics the 2014 issue
there is a series where she goes to matt
murdock to go discuss uh breaking the
law basically like how do we fight
sometimes when we know that they're
wrong and he was talking about how
uh matt murdock wouldn't do this but
daredevil broke into a prison and
released someone from prison with
spider-man just because they were
wrongfully accused but they weren't
wrongfully accused by the jury the jury
found them guilty but they were like no
our friend was wrongly accused broke
them out and he said let me let me look
at my notes he said okay
he said the question you need to ask
yourself jen is this about your client
or is it about you
and i think jen is gonna be dealing with
so many looking in the mirror moments of
like is this wrong is this right i think
it's gonna be kind of the same thing
that we expected with miss marvel where
it's like in the comics where she was
like i don't want to be a hero because
as a hero i keep hurting people so i
think jen is going to be like i just
wanted to be a lawyer but then her
lawyer part is going to be conflicted
because it's going to be like well these
people aren't wrong these people are
right these superheroes aren't wrong the
government's wrong and then she'll be
looking at bruce and be like why are you
fighting for something that consciously
is wrong and he's gonna be like well
just doing my job and then we're gonna
get into this civil war kind of moment
where it's like whose side are you on
and when the thunderbolts present
themselves she's going to be like i
agree with
at least two of the three people so far
maybe not johnny mayonnaise but i do
think that she's gonna like they present
it more so that like we're not the
government government we're working as a
different thing right so i think she's
gonna see that and be like
yeah i kind of agree with what they're
saying and i could see her potentially
being that kind of leader figure for the
thunderbolts and she'll be fighting with
johnny manny's 24 7 or
she'll be trying to defend them after
they see what she gets that she does to
abomination uh we'll have julie louis
dreyfus show up and be like
can you defend us
and then that's when she's gonna become
a part of the thunderbolts
does that make sense does that make
sense no i re i dig this a lot i dig
this a lot considering that we know that
um general ross wants the power of a
hulk it's some capacity like he he's
always wanted that he doesn't like bruce
the person he does not like bruce at all
but he really likes the power of the
hulk and so like if she hulk is like on
his team like even though like we all
know that general ross is not going to
be in the future of the mcu do the
passing of the actor but like i can
definitely see um the the having a hulk
on that team being something that it
happens in the future and i can
definitely see jen wanting to represent
all these people especially if like
bucky is on that team because like bucky
is a very uh mixed up man who has a very
troubled past and the
uh you know a lot of he was forgiven for
his crimes okay or even he was
brainwashed
her with her with elena when elena was
literally brainwashed i could see her
being like well those crimes were
against her
she didn't consent to any of that she
was brainwashed by him
child trafficked uh abused and then set
out on the world like it's not her fault
it's not her fault so i think and i
think
non-huma or non-superpower people are
gonna see it that way of like she killed
my sister and it's like but they did it
against their will it's not their fault
that they're just stronger than most and
i think that's gonna be jennifer walters
take because in the comics jennifer
walters messes up a lot like will she
hulk messes up so much she
indirectly hurts a lot of people and or
indirectly yeah indirectly he's like not
she's not going out of her way to hurt
these people yeah not on purpose she
indirectly hurts and harms a lot of
people she smashes cars cars get in the
way just like hulk did at the beginning
you know so i think it's going to be a
lot of her being like these people are
doing this beyond their control they
couldn't do they couldn't help this um
do i agree with it all the time no
jessica clements do i agree with it all
the time no
but i feel like matt murdock and her are
gonna have that situation where matt's
like well it's a crime and we follow the
law and we follow the justice system and
she's gonna be like yeah but it's not
always right and he's gonna be like well
that's not our choice to make up that's
not her choice to decide i love it
i really i really love this idea of like
jen
challenging like pretty much everything
that she's known because of this new
experience that she's had being a hulk
and being a superhero so she's like yeah
like of course i'm gonna join the
thunderbolts because like
they they're not with all this u.s
government bs like i've i've i've dealt
with the system and it does it's so
stupid so like let's let's hulk out for
a little bit i i dig it i dig it
it also depends on like where it i where
is it on the timeline i guess it depends
on where it is on the timeline because
if she saw how they were treating falcon
when he became captain america she could
be like i kind of want to fight with the
people that aren't really like treating
him like [ __ ]
but i guess johnny mayonnaise was kind
of this man a freaking bank loan for the
love of god god damn yeah god forbid we
give this a man that fought for us a lot
of money a bank that he'll pay back that
he'll pay yeah i think you're right on
the money jess because i think she's
gonna be like
yeah use see that the government's using
her as like a poster child
she's gonna see the system that they've
put into place that these people can't
win and that the government is using
these laws to keep these super humans
like under their thumb and use them as
they want and she's gonna see like how
abomination emil blonsky was tricked
into taking a super soldier serum was
lied to was almost killed and then his
his whole physiology was changed it
messed with his mind he's out of his
mind he doesn't know what he's doing and
now and now they got wong with have him
on a tight leash taking him to an
illegal underground fight to make money
what's going on here
and you know bruce is gonna be like well
we gotta work within the system and it's
just going to be like screw the system
it's a system
yeah she's going to be so mad at bruce
for being like you're the strongest man
in the world why have you not stopped
this why have you not broken the chains
of your oppressors and she's gonna be
i'm gonna stand in it and then val's
gonna hit her at the right moment and be
like do you wanna make some change do
you really wanna change something
yeah i'm gonna wanna change some things
[Music]
okay baby
julia dreyfus is gonna show up
completely and be like so i got a deal
for you i got a deal for you also and
john walker's gonna be like yeah let's
let's be friends and she'll be like stay
away from me john walker don't talk to
me she's gonna be like wait aren't you
thinking i saw that viral video i saw
that video did you kill that guy
um
that's also what i was like people
because i was talking to my mom about it
and she was like wasn't that guy that
like executed someone publicly on that
team and i was like yeah so i think they
need someone like she-hulk to like
counter-balance that horrible deed like
it they're gonna have to do a lot i i
don't think we have to be team
thunderbolts but i think there's gonna
be that situation where like killmonger
where we're like oh i see their point of
view and i you guys are gonna have to
really sway me with that point of view
for me to be okay with that man on that
team so i think putting she-hulk and
like elena bolova who the audience are
already really interested interested in
will kind of okay but the balance is
still off i think johnny mayonnaise is
gonna have to do a lot to redeem himself
i think well i think he can i think he
can be redeemed jessica in in so much is
the fact that like he again was used by
his country he was he was in the
military who knows what happened to him
in the military he gets a serum injected
into him yeah he volunteered for it but
what he told was going to happen and
what actually happened were vastly
different and then his good friend got
killed poor battle star all right for me
for me it still does shut the [ __ ] up
empty for me it doesn't it still doesn't
win i'm like you publicly did it though
like if you i know i know you but he's
he needed help he was a man who needed
help he needed psychology he needed
mental health he needed something in his
psd he yeah he needed something
he wasn't getting that help from the
very government that put him in that
position they need to
they need to get into that then maybe a
little bit before thunderbolt i think
that's how you can first thing of
thunderbolts you need to get into that
because i am still only remembering
everyone's cameras on him just smashed
it yeah
one of the most gruesome things that
we've ever seen at the end of the year
that might be honestly the darkest thing
i've seen in the mcu for me it's a
public execution
yeah no i'm good
i'm sorry
can't get more darker than that a good
old public execution
classic i think it's time for the
judgment time because i think that this
theory is pretty dang good so i'm going
to give this
um a pretty a rogue it's a go thumbs up
double rogue is actually two double
rogues thumbs up
you know jessica came to me yesterday
she pitched me the idea and that's how
you win baby rogue it's rogues
i love it
no this is a this is a good this is a
good idea and i really like this idea of
like
giving us a thunderbolts team that is
not
just solely super evil
people you know what i mean like i'm
never going to agree with venom but like
yeah you throw she-hulk on there you
throw elena bolova on there i'm
listening i'm listening to what they say
yeah 100 100
and that's how you do it i would
especially love if they had both
she-hulk and red she-hulk in this show
because like the show is the
thunderbolts and like it's all about
like ross's legacy and like his daughter
who would it was like what it'd be like
yeah yeah yeah no like um his daughter
is the red she-hulk in the comics so
like i feel like bringing her back and
having her be red she-hulk would be
really fun to have them both team up
they're gonna have a show it's going to
be the show's going to be called hulk
house whole kaipas okay and it's going
to be all the hulk
living in a house along with abomination
he's there too baby and it's like
they're trying to become hype uh you
know they're trying to become like
instagram stars tic tac stars
they all have different rooms and
actually making the band yeah yeah i'm
like i like obama nation because he's
sexy
and instead of like instead of a pool
they just have like rocks and heavy
stuff in the backyard that they work out
with exactly you know what i mean it'd
be like exactly they'd be like yo
she-hulk keeps eating all my granola
it's [ __ ] up like i have my name on it
like what's going on it's like man she's
really messing up my carb intake like i
need my carbs my proteins to be equal
like oh my god i gotta make my games i'm
so gonna make my gains my green gains
exactly you can't you can't slack on
those gains not at all but now it's time
for us to gain
a rogue question into our life that's a
bad transition i'm sorry no is it
beautiful don't bail don't bail you had
it
land the plane land the plane
it is time for the wrong question are
you guys ready for this one i'm ready
it's pretty good because news came out
this week that the flash will be ending
after its ninth season on the cw my like
that smallville status at this point
yeah my god what a run
in honor of these monster of the week
superhero shows like you know aero
smallville and legends of tomorrow that
have always been there for us over the
years pitch me your rogue is hero that
you would like to see get a teen focused
episodic show on their own
oh too many that's the two parts
i want i want teen version of every
single one of them i want riverdale for
the avengers i would watch i would eat
that [ __ ]
i mean if they could really i love i
grew up on smallville like these shows
it's easy to like look back and be like
ah they're so bad or like ah you know
whatever but they're important and they
have like a good part and they get us
through the lean years you know what i
mean it's it's easy now with all these
movies but back then we didn't have a
lot of superheroes stuff back in my day
we didn't have a lot of sugar stores
but i would love they tried this in the
90s it didn't work they only did a pilot
but i mean if they really did one of
these like young adult shows for the
x-men about being at the xavier school
for the gifted and like really
coming-of-age stuff you know uh i i
think that would be cool have like some
of the older x-men be the teachers you
know have storm as a teacher have
wolverine have jean grey as a teacher
but get us some like young
mutants like really going to school the
trials and tribulations of learning to
be a hero while learning to be a best
friend i think that would be a really
good one i would love it i would watch
that man that gives me x-men evolution
vibes
yeah like yes exactly like that cartoon
yes yes yes yes yeah that's what i want
i wanted
the old x-men teachers and the young
kids put them in that danger room put
their lives on the line you know what
i'm talking about like
damn
put those kids in the danger room
you're like oh you didn't turn in your
book report gotta go up against the
holographic sentinel sorry kid you
better put you in the danger room
you brought this on yourself
i want
a
second roster
kind of like
marvel
teen show and when i say second roster i
want the star of the show to be task
master
i want it to be taskmaster because i
think it would be fun to watch a teenage
taskmaster in high school or even like
young high school so like they're still
kind of puberty uh just literally seeing
popular people and like copying what
they're doing
and either becoming really cool or being
the number one loser like people be like
oh that kid he just bites our style and
he's just like whatever i can also be
the number one football player watch me
be literally the best at lacrosse watch
me literally win
anything like i can join the
cheerleading team and be the best
cheerleader because i watched the number
one do it and i'm gonna do it uh and
just like i it could be like even like a
rom-com where like he's in love with
someone or like i don't know i just want
him to kind of fall the climax is gonna
be his fault and then he's gonna get
back up and he's gonna be fine it could
even be like normal people where like in
high school he's really cool but in
college people are like you're fake as
[ __ ] like yeah
taskmaster is like at the top of his
game coming out of high school because
he's copied everyone they think he's the
best he goes into college and it's like
no one cares about your high school
credit no he's gonna start over you know
what i mean he doesn't know who to copy
in college first he's playing hacky sack
uh uh then he's like you know he's gotta
go do uh
now
bmxer i don't know yes yes so the story
is him being like i wanna find out what
i like to do what i enjoy
yeah he's gonna join like an art class
and then be the best and people would be
like why and he's like
i don't know i'm just good at everything
that any other person
[Laughter]
um what do you call it when you drop out
of college
yeah i'll call a task master dropout or
something dropout task
i really dig this idea of like you know
like taskmaster through a teen's
perspective because like that's exactly
what a team would do it's like i want to
be super popular and like just copy
everyone and just be number one uh but i
don't know who i am so no i like this i
will give you the rogue question winner
trophy for today because that's really
fun yes and i could totally see that on
the cw if the cw had the rights
if they had the rights
no i would watch that show but like i'm
just glad that cw is not yeah in charge
of marvel because that's something just
give them one character one character
and then like one only taskmaster
don't do anything else but that is it
for this episode of rogue theory a huge
thank you to our guests jessica clemons
and off-screen producer brandon please
follow them on their social medias and
live and support everything that they do
they're amazing people and you can
support our channel by checking out all
of our amazing merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
uh and if you got some rogue theories of
your own you can share them on our
discord if you're over 18 just search
for the new rockstar discord server and
join the conversation today you can
follow me at mastertainment if you want
to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] you can
follow me rockstars everywhere we are on
social media and make sure you hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video you guys love you we guys love you
doesn't make any sense um we love you
guys so much thank you guys for watching
and we will see you guys next time
goodbye
bye
[Music]
you